hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game from the protest League it is
the former women's world champion
Alexandre costenuka and also former
women's rapid Champion I think she won
the rapid championship in 2021 uh versus
the Magnus Carlsen the the
um still reigning world champion uh it's
quite a game and the two of them have
faced each other uh so far four times
and uh the result is three to one in
magnus's favor uh she defeated Magnus in
2009 in the world of Blitz championship
and it was quite a brutal game she
defeated him with the black pieces and
it's the first time Magnus actually won
the world the blitz Championship he he
wanted three full points ahead of
ishwanathan Anand but he he lost a very
nice nice game to her so this is a
chance for her to level the score a
little bit so let's see what happened in
the game she opened with Ponte E4 we
have Pawn to see five Magnus goes for
the Sicilian Defense Knight to F3 with
Knight to C6 and now Bishop to B5 in the
defeated uh Carlson she went for D4 it
was also a Sicilian Defense but here
Bishop to B5 and of course we all know
what Magnus plays against the rosolimo
or against the Nish Medina rosalimo
attack he goes for Ponte G6 uh we have
castles Bishop to G7 C3 and pawn to A6
now challenging the bishop she captures
on C6 Bishop captures D captures and now
a standard uh here is D3 or D4 but also
Pawn to H3 which he goes for uh this
allows Magnus to just grab more space
with E5 and now he controls the D4
square and now D3 is a known move also
Queen to E2 is a normal but she plays
Knight the A3 and it is now as of move
seven that we have a completely new game
uh we have Queen to C7 by magnet you
could also try to play around this
knight move uh maybe with a move like B5
preventing Knight to C4 or you could
maybe go for the very annoying Queen to
D3 but if you don't know if it works uh
Magnus just sticks the what
C7 square is excellent for the queen in
this line quantity three and now Knight
to F6 or maybe Magnus even knows the
entire line with Knight A3 and he knows
that maybe Queen to C7 is better than
Queen to D3 uh we can never know how
deep um a magnus's knowledge really goes
uh Bishop to E3 with Knight to D7 now
uh and now Queen to D2 preparing the
trade of the dark Square Bishops after
Magnus castles that's exactly what
happens we have castles and the bishop
to H6 so this is a very strong Bishop of
course you want to trade it and uh
somehow try to attack the black king the
ideal setup is you want to get your
queen to H6 and somehow put your knight
on G5 and of course Checkmate the black
king uh of course that's easier said
than done with rooked E8 by Magnus and
now Bishop characters King characters
and now Knight to C4 so now that the
Knight is on C4 Magnus executes B5 with
Knight to E3 and Knight back to F6 you
no longer need the Knight on D7 to guard
the C5 Pawn so C4 uh it's uh it's a move
you maybe maybe would rather avoid
because you leave
um your D3 Pawn a bit weak but uh okay
uh she does have a plan on how she she
wants to play around that C4 we have B
for by Magnus which is extremely strong
as it prevents a wife from executing B4
so B3 and pawn to A5 we have Pawn to A3
not preparing to open up the a file and
Bishop to E6 by Magnus Queen to B2 now
nicely aligning the queen with the black
king so you have to be careful of some
uh sacrifices and also uh the pawn here
is just hanging for the moment it's
attacked twice and defended once unlike
the D7 again Magnus defends it and now
eight captures on B4 with C characters
keeping the a file uh closed uh at some
point you will have A4 and then uh
regardless of what happens you're either
getting the the past a pawn or the past
B Pawn or white will capture and then
you again get the pass B Pawn so Magnus
knows that at some point in the future
of this game he is getting a pass Pawn
on the queen side and here we have
Knight the G5 basically a solid weight
to go would be Pawn to D4 uh it makes
sense you just open up this diagonal for
example e captures now if Queen cap
respawn to F6 and if Knight captures
then again Pawn to F6 and basically uh
F4 and white is very solid here however
she went for night the G5 instead of
putting pressure on the bishop here
Magnus plays F6 strengthens the E5 Pawn
Knight captures with Rook captures and
now Pawn to D4 but now it's a little bit
different and it's very very subtle why
it's different he captures on D4 Queen
captors and now Queen to D6 looks like
uh looks like a pretty standard move but
it's extremely strong because it's very
unclear how to continue this game for
white the problem is if you just double
up let's say play Rook F to D1 uh Magnus
will trade captures captures and play
Knight C5 and the two weaknesses on B3
and D4 cannot be defended you're just
gonna lose the pawn and you're gonna
lose the game another reason why it's uh
very hard to Parry this is because if
you trade Queens which is uh another
pretty pretty basic idea Rook captures
there's uh again how do you how do you
counter Knight the C5 you could go for
Knight to C2 with the idea of Knight
captures on B4 because the a pawn is
pinned but still Knight C5 and if Knight
captures on B4 just Knight captures and
B3 again you have your past a pawn
doesn't really matter where the root
goes even if you attack the Knight Pawn
to E4 you have a Monster Pawn here you
have a monster Knight here it's a
beautiful position for white it will be
very hard to hold so instead she went
back a queen to B2 and it makes sense
okay you do wanna keep the Queens on the
board as magnus's king is a is a bit
more loose than the white king and G1 uh
we have Queen to E5 again Magnus offers
a queen trade and queen to B2 again she
declines and attacks the Knight on D7
Rook to D6 attacks the queen queen to C1
and now Pawn to H5 and now it's very
very difficult to to make a move here
with white how do you how do you proceed
here is there is there a good way uh to
deal with this position uh the the E4
Pawn is still hanging so uh obviously
there's that but uh the the Knight the
C5 uh move once it lands again your B3
and E4 will become very very weak so she
knows she's gonna have to give up some
material so she decides to give up a
material but on her own terms she plays
Pawn to C5 which frees up the C4 Square
for the knight uh and okay uh Magnus
accepts Queen captures on C5 now comes
Knight to the Sea for attacking The Rook
Rook to D4 and now Rook the D1 now you
can't go after D4 Pawn because again the
Knight on D7 hangs uh and Magnus plays
Pawn to A4 now is the moment where the
pass Pawn will be created and here she
played Rook captures on D4 uh a nice a
nice idea also was just Rook captures an
A4 because well especially because the
Knight and D7 is very vulnerable and now
if Magnus trades let's say Rook captures
B captures and queen captures because
you don't have a better move uh you just
trade a queen capris on C4 Rook captures
and now Rook captures on D7 with check
King H6 Rook to B7 will put pressure on
the b-pawn let's say a capture Sun E4
now King comes into the game and now
upon the C5 but she would also have the
past a pawn which would be sufficient
for for a draw however in the game after
this A4 move Rook captures on D form uh
was played
uh let's not forget that this is a rapid
chest uh and now comes Queen captures on
D4 and she basically forces Magnus into
a winning position and here again you
could play Rook captures on A4 if Rook
captures B captures and then something
like Knight the C5 comes again puts
pressure on both the the E Pawn and the
a pawn uh but maybe okay maybe it will
be possible to hold uh a bit easier but
not hold maybe it would be possible to
survive a bit longer but here she played
Queen to E1 she's going for the uh for
the attack so you have to be very
careful what what you do here but Magnus
just plays Knight the C1 the real threat
is Rook to D1 just putting pressure on
the queen and the Knights on Knight the
C5 and now Rook to D1 attacks the queen
and queen to C3 just offering a queen
trade and uh being very annoying with
Queen to E2 a character some B3 Magnus
creates a past Pawn with Ponte E5 she
breaks through the the white king the
black King's defenses but now just Rook
to A1 I will get at least one of the
attackers of the board so he captures an
F6 with check King captures and now Rook
captures on A1 we have Queen captures on
A1 with check King to H2 and now Queen
to D4 so nicely centralizing the queen
and now uh if you if you count the pawns
magnets is up two pawns okay this is a
double Pawn so maybe you can count that
as one Pawn but either way if you don't
have the attack you are losing this game
so she plays Pawn to G3 uh preventing
any any checks and now comes Knight to
D3 and now okay df2 Pawn is hanging
Queen to F3 with check King to G7 and
now you really uh have ran out of moves
there's really not much you can you can
play here uh if you just defend the pawn
with King to G2 it's not all that
spectacular nice day one check we'll
pick up the queen if you play something
like King to G1 then the Knight here
hangs so uh combining all of this it's
very hard to find the move she played
Queen captures in C6 it defends the
night but now you have to give up the F2
Pawn so here Queen captures an F2 check
was played King to H1 Queen to G3 now
threatening Knight the F2 Checkmate uh
here she plays Queen to D7 with check
Magnus played King to H6 and he was in
this position on move 43 that Alexandra
costenuk resigned to the game as there
is nothing more uh to be done here
Knight to have to check is coming so it
will either be Checkmate as there are no
more useful checks you could play
something like this but we said what we
think about moves like that
on this channel uh so this is either
Checkmate or you play something like
Queen F7 and then you have to give up
the queen after a check but of course
again that is pointless uh so yeah very
nicely done their their fifth game uh
goes to Magnus so now the the
head-to-head score is four to one in
magnus's favor so we'll see yeah what
happens in the future
uh so yeah very nicely done uh it it it
seemed like uh she wanted to avoid going
into an equal end game against Magnus
and she just wanted to keep um uh the
the position More Alive she wanted to
keep attacking chances on the board uh
and at some point
um I actually just lost the the threat
of the game especially when Agnes just
found this very elegant Queen to D6 move
uh just you know absolutely stunning a
simple but but elegant uh so yeah once
again I really hope you guys enjoyed
this today yeah for those of you who
don't know Alexandra a question you
could no longer represents Russia she
switched Federation she is now
representing Switzerland so if you guys
are interested in that uh but yeah I
would like to thank the John Berry day
Lobo ravishing reptiles YouTube and Joe
wildeers for your contribution to my
channel think we wanted to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest